لعنه الوثائق السريه لا تزال تلاحق الرئيس
الامريكي جوبايلين
سته وثائق جديده عثر عليها هذه المره في
منزل بايدين البحث استمرق الرابط اثني عشر
ساعه وشملت كل اماكن العمل والمعيشه
والتخزين في المنزل لحظه غياب بيض وزوجته
اثناء التفتيش الوثائق الست عود لفتره
عضويته في مجلس الشيوخ واخرى اثناء توليه
منصب نائب الرئيس باراك اوباما تضاف
الوثائق الست الى وثائق اخرى عثر عليها في
مقر اقامه بعيد في الثانيه عشر من الشعر
الجاري ووثائق اخرى عثر عليها في مكتبه
السابق في مركز ابحاث بوشنطن
وثيقه اخرى تضع الديمقراطيين في موقف لا
يحسدون عليه بعد ان وجهه كثيرا من
الانتقادات الى الرئيس السابق الجمهوري
دونالد ترامب الذي يخضع هو الاخر لتحقيق
قضائي الاحتفاظ باكثر من مئه وثيقه سريه
على الرغم من مغادرته واشنطن عام 2021 اما
الرئيس فيقف امام اسئله ملحه تدور حول تلك
الوثائق فحواها ومدى خطورتها عصام عبد
السلام العربيه